hey and welcome to another episode of
riffin wit griffin want to thank
everybody that listens and you send your
comments you send your theme songs you
send all your love and I really
appreciate it
and once again I have another special
episode I say this every time that it's
a special episode but this one truly is
a special episode so before I go into
this week's theme song let me introduce
to the program the very funny in town to
mr. Tony Rock thank you sir thanks for
having me I'm glad you here man I know
you know a bit more you made it seem
like this was more specialized it's more
special because nobody has black people
on their podcast can I just give you
some love - we go to the game listen I
just have clipper tickets because they
were cheaper than Laker tickets and I'm
a Brooklyn Nets fan but since I'm in
spending more time in LA I had to see
basketball you ain't [ __ ] so I'm not I
love the other day was playing Brooklyn
Brooklyn and Brooklyn was up 20 can I
leave please have you are you really a
Brooklyn Nets face man
oh wow okay so you must have loved but
those years they went to the champions
no no I was in a row the the where the
Barclays Center sits right used to be
the hub for the New York Daily News oh
and my father worked for the New York
Daily News my entire childhood we don't
get into there so all right let me get
Hilton has transitioned as Brooklyn has
went through its Renaissance and
gentrification its went from a hub of
daily news to basketball in Brooklyn so
they both have a tie I want to hear all
about your your life story the the
genesis of who Tony rock is but first
this is our this week's theme song see
Peterson is a Brian Hanna original
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a good one shout out Brian Hannah
all right nice short but sweet on that
one right there okay so here we are you
know I've known you for many years a
long time yes you know but is it a fan
of your work for some time every
birthday show I do I try to get you a
birthday show you got it was on that
time is he gonna be on it I was
especially on fire that yes yes only
because it was just so knowing you that
yeah you know and everybody knew it was
like cleaning right that that was in the
room
that's what stand-up comedy is like
today that funny on the spot yeah just
know yeah you just cuz you are you know
you were ladies man
you know you I have some female friends
gonna be something he don't want to
answer so you got a whole phone that was
the great that was a great that you
killed attention to the obvious in the
room it was very I remember the lot I
said a lot be with a lot of ladies here
tonight think they with Tony you
language on you say what's gonna you a
with Tony let us say some even if you
came with Tony
you a with Tony I'm sure I got you in
trouble that night killed you know what
I remember about that birthday night
looked at Pookie yeah remember yeah here
remember he had the not differential
acquit
but they
you don't have a hypnotist or in a black
show yeah yeah
it was like some guy he wanted to do a
favor but he wanted to do a favor on my
birthday chenille birthday show that's
tonight he's doing hypnosis in a black
was like yeah I work him bro and then
the fake people he had come up these
dudes yeah Dave felt on comfy
yeah unbelievably at night but memorable
I appreciate that I appreciate you for
having me on your I'm a fan of your work
too I'm like I've known you see again
your obvious let's just get the elephant
out of the room right away
you know Tony rod brother of Chris Rock
little brother of Chris big brother of
Jordan big brother Jordan so it's like
like I'm wondering if y'all gonna have
like a basketball game first of
weigh-ins this is a Brian I'll be the
Raider let me cool but when you see you
front you guys you hold your family's
from New York I want amazing Baptist
Abbas in Brooklyn my parents from South
Carolina okay we were gone and raised we
City kids I gotta tell people as I'm a
city boy with country morals and values
because my mother was sent us to South
Carolina every summer to stay at my
grandparents oh wow I'm still yes ma'am
no ma'am hold door treating them in a
certain way you know but I'm still city
boy so I know when somebody's gonna get
robbed and receipted I see when it's
going down before other people do like
you walk beside out but anyway so you
are I see you had a big family I have
seven brothers and two sisters Chris
Andre Tony Derek Brian Kenny Quan Andy
Jordan and who's the oldest Charles he
passed away I'm sorry
r.i.p yeah and how much older or Charles
was Charles was 18 and in prison when I
was born
oh my god oh yeah he was he was he was a
wild guy yeah he was very Street
he was uh he was Street a street celeb
he was a hood celeb in our neighborhood
we were famous for being his little
brothers oh wow
so we gonna barbershop it's like hey
don't let it arise we feel topography
boy yeah that's Charles little brother
like you know Wow and so but that's like
18 years makes it where well obviously
also going to prison but it makes it but
you can't really be close you're not no
it's the family clothes it's like I had
two dads growing up the young cool day
that was like you know just how you
dressed it's how you talk to girls
taught me how to box play basketball and
then I had my dad dad who was home work
cleaning your room brushing teeth you
know get the groceries out the car like
he was Stern and didn't play well my
oldest brother was like you know a
little more lenient like come on man
like don't just come on sneak out the
house with me let's go let's go some
pizza don't eat was for dinner and
calling super cool dude that's super
funny and was everybody funny
everybody's funny yeah it's a it's a
weird thing it's like I didn't know with
that many siblings I didn't know that
people had siblings that weren't funny
right so when my other friends would
come over they were pissed be so blown
away with my family and how we all
played around with each other and we
were so close and we would pick on each
other but still it was all loving right
and you know a little fist fighting here
but it was all loving my friends and
like be blown away like this is not my
family's not like this so all my friends
and another thing growing up in Brooke
and Bev stops in Brooklyn the street I
grew up on sad to say my father was
maybe one of five fathers on the whole
block oh wow so he was a father not to
just and ultimately he's probably a
father to like some of your friends and
people that's not you know brownstone
houses and yeah yeah yeah real close so
I'm about 25 houses on each side maybe
yeah I got family from Staten Island
same houses five fathers huh so my dad
was my boy's father Aaron's father my
homegirl on the cross he was everybody's
father
well now surprised that the family's so
successful yeah right yeah dad was uh he
was he was he taught us a lot you know
how much older is how much older is
Kristen you us eight years
oh we were you guys like did you find
yourself being close you know what's
weird about our relationship
when you little brother you want to
follow Big Brother everywhere but Big
Brother's always like come on make it
out of here like you cramping my style
like come on could I go no I'm with my
friends we're older by the way you are a
thousand times cooler than Chris you
like your you I bet you going like Chris
like I'll be the store to factories here
sometimes I can I get a picture with
your brother and I'm like hey oh man oh
thank you so much like he would've never
did it yeah yeah yeah I'd I think it's
all because we treat him like he's we
call him Chrissy he's Chrissy for
serious like he's just Chrissy does so
that's cool me and always treated in the
same way so I mean it's like I mean it's
it must be something because your
brother's such a giant in comedy yeah
he's established himself there's like
literally one of the greats
I know especially if our era to me still
one of the best specials in the last
thirty years still just because of even
the impact of it and like seeing
somebody do that
so then what made you go oh I want to do
that too well no I
I want it to be a comic from school bus
you know like I would listen to Richard
Pryor albums at home I would listen to
George Carlin my father had Flip Wilson
my father had Redd Foxx my father had
moms maybe though so keep in mind my
father back story some more back story
my father's the oldest of 15 oh my god
just a [ __ ] my big bro to nine on TV and
the neighborhood so on a Saturday you
know in the summertime we have a cookout
in the backyard yeah my pops will throw
a record on and all my uncles are there
dying laughing at Richard Pryor and all
Flip Wilson throws that on and they oh
I'm just like the feeling that I see in
this room I want to be a part of this
word I want to be a part of everybody
laughing and having a great time even
even apart from your brother do the same
thing this is your own life six years
old right right right now I'm in school
the next day telling Richard Pryor jokes
and saying trying to quote what Redd
Foxx said I'm cursin of course yeah yeah
yeah and my teachers like what are you
what are you saying
I heard this stuff on and all my friends
is just dying laughing on a school bus
right and uh my mother's like you can't
say that in school this is this is a
album this is but he does he does this
for a job he's he doesn't you know I see
British Prime TV right it's the guy from
the record yeah he does
records he does TV alright he does
movies and I'm like well okay I have to
be this guy now was your mom at that
time and dad and let's say encouraging
you to go into a different career yeah
of course my mother was a schoolteacher
okay she want you to get your degree
education degree college marry a college
sweetheart
boom my dad was a blue-collar truck
driver hard-working worked my father
worked two full-time jobs my father
worked 80 hours a week so his thing was
work work work work work work nobody's
giving you nothing you responsible for
your own life nobody's coming to save
you so that work ethic was instilled in
us mom wanted to traditional route but
then you know the bug came in the comedy
bug and yeah like okay if I can apply
that work ethic
right right right take on this then yeah
yeah yeah I could still be successful
right right so uh for myself that was it
it was like I was telling jokes and
stuff in school and uh then Eddie Murphy
hit and Eddie Murphy was a young black
guy right a cool black guy and I wanted
to be I was a young black guy I wanted
to be cool he was the epitome of
stand-up at the time now Saturday no no
Saturday Night Live around that time
like this is this is me that's what it
was from a height of Eddie Eddie's
Rockstar status after delirious or you
know this around the same time right
Eddie just yeah yeah I guess everybody's
yeah you know stratosphere and we're
around the TV every Saturday night and
the whole family's like this guy's the
biggest and I'm like okay this is that
feeling again yeah we're all around the
TV because of this guy and my family's
laughing and my brothers and my boys
live down the street they don't have TVs
in the house and it's like I have to be
a part of this feeling mm-hmm
so I didn't know Eddie I didn't know
Richard Pryor I didn't know George
Carlin it was like no I love them but I
don't know then the guy in the next room
is doing stand-up right it turns into oh
[ __ ] this is
could be real oh that I could really be
this guy you already felt like you could
do it yeah but I was nothing about my
friends my friends thought I was the
funniest kind of world right I was sit
on the stoop on a Saturday afternoon we
had to do our chores first my mother
would put a list of chores on the
refrigerator by like 10:00 in the
morning she would tape chores for
everybody
she's like I'm only child yes it was
like y'all had a little I had to sweep
the front yard pick up the leaves I had
to wash dishes wash the bath clean the
bathroom downstairs take the laundry out
the dryer wash be put in a dryer my
brother Brian had to you know vacuum
everybody's room make beds and take
everybody had a list of stuff to do and
then when it was done I would go outside
and sit on a stoop with my boys and the
the the routine we had every Saturday
was I was sit on the stoop and everybody
that won't pass I had to roast them
everybody so if you just walking down
the street I'm like you big looking like
look like a damn potato sack you know in
the hood there's a million characters
yeah it's a crackhead walk there's a man
a white male man too short dress that's
like there's so much stuff to get you
know so I'm just and my boys just dying
laughing and I'm many fights happened
did anybody go like like how do you
design this is this is 10 12 oh my god
okay yeah so I'm just like that's our
Saturday then uh so my brother starts to
understand my brothers standing on line
for tickets to see Eddie Murphy at
Madison Square Garden he's at Radio City
or Madison Square Garden ah sure fer fer
de Leary he's standing on because the
lord have mercy lord have mercy to her
all right now it was like he was torn
for that yes so my brother's on line to
get tickets and lines like insanely
around the building two times and uh he
gets his tickets and then he walks to
the comic strip and signs up for the mic
so now he goes and does the open mic he
doesn't tell my mother because my mother
he's in Community College at the time
does the open mic they pass him
he's a regular at the comic strip Wow
he's sneaking going to Community College
during today going to work at Red
Lobster on Queens Boulevard
leaving driving to the city to do spots
sleeping in his car coming home get a
little bit of rest get up in the morning
go back to school school to work work to
strip so my brother Andre finds out
about it and Andre starts going around
with him like I'll meet you at the comic
strip I'll Andre had a motorcycle it's I
don't know you know it Andre knows I saw
I'm still like you okay hey can I go no
get out of here man can I come no get
out of here
all right but then Andres like yo like
so Chrissy on stage last night was so
funny and I'm like okay well I want to
see this so now he's taking me to the
strip um yeah you got sneak in the back
yeah yeah yeah back there sitting in the
darkness and it's like you don't touch
anything just watch the show
I see Eddie Murphy at his height
I see Jerry Seinfeld I see Paul Reiser I
see Adam Sandler I see my brother Dennis
wolfburg mark shift
I see Joel bolster all these blowing my
mind every night I knew you were going
regularly yeah like if I could you know
I can I come like yeah oh come on
Saturday night you know nothing I don't
have to be in school
come on this is like the most incredible
thing I'm witnessing in my life I'm
watching these guys I don't know how
they're coming up with material I don't
know the prices right right
I just know every guys coming on after
the next guy and he's funny as that than
the last guy that's the era where it
felt like magic you know it's always
felt like magic to me yeah always felt
I'm just watching these guys like how do
I do this like what you know and - at
that time - you're also watching your
brother watching my what you think of
your brother the first time you saw I've
always think he's my brother so I'm like
you know just see him up there as like
cool as a kid to see your brother doing
anything is like oh snap you know you
see your brother playing basketball give
me sucks it's like oh he's out there
like this that's cool you know uh and
he's like hit him is sometimes not like
that no way
no wait near the guy to shoot people's
yeah it's like some nicely in the collet
he's like ah damn that didn't work you
know yeah and uh he's just but the work
ethic is still that I was just about to
say you know one thing a side note is
one thing I now I'm just because I'm
hearing your origin story right I
realized as part of his origin story
right and one thing I always appreciate
you may appreciate about him she'll come
to the store and be like hey lower your
expectations right cuz he's working on
something yeah yeah then I see it three
weeks later and it's like so that's
that's part of this family the rock
working right and you know he told me a
fast forward did not come back yeah wow
this is like I'm doing stand-up I'm in
for like maybe a couple years and he
calls me one days like yeah you had a
set last night and I was like to strip
like yeah killed I did seven minutes
murder murder killed him seven minutes
when's your next spot tomorrow he calls
me the next night how was you said I
killed again I killed again
two nights later what'd you do I killed
man I'm telling you an actual question
did you do the same set all three times
yeah okay well then call me when you
bomb and I said why is that he said
because you're not taking chances until
you're bombing hmm so you can do the
same set seven minutes set forever and
you know what there's also gonna be but
when you take a chance and start trying
the material and it doesn't go your way
that's when you learn how to do it so
that's when it was like okay now I got
to go up sometimes and not be so
consumed with what the audience thinks
it's like I'm working this out for later
on you guys you just have to sit through
maybe a hit maybe in right I find a
nugget maybe it's nothing but you're
gonna have to sit through it you know
now I think a lot of comics get consumed
with making that particular audience
laugh that they don't take the chance to
go let me try this new bit cuz the
people are staring right at them and
they don't want to step outside of that
and really try to be you gotta you gotta
be you gotta risk bombing to be great
yeah yeah for sure most guys will just
be like I'll just be good in the room
I'll just be good right here
interesting I feel like the moment you
really feel like you're there I think
you finally feel growth as a stand-up
when you actually don't give a [ __ ]
about the crowd right like you literally
just like I'm working on this and I feel
this way you know what that's the best
life yeah and you don't give a [ __ ]
about what people say about you yeah you
are free you don't give a [ __ ] about
what people think about what you're
wearing or how you look is that's the
biggest the greatest freedom you're
gonna have and when you're on stage and
you
care this is what I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say like this I'm not saying this
for you guys the biggest misconception
is that people think that comics on
stage saying things that we think that
they think is funny right we're saying
[ __ ] we think is funny by the way that's
the problem that a lot of young calm
yeah we're saying well we think it's
funny if you laugh then you agree right
but I'm saying should I think it's funny
sometimes you can laugh you laugh even
when you disagree right you know you're
laughing like are you stupid
right right that's fine but at least
respect the creativity of what I took
the time to write you know I mean now
one thing I'm realizing right now from
talking to you is that you wanted to do
your own thing you had your own path
yeah because I always wonder why yeah
because if you look at the Wayans
mm-hmm you know they they're always
around each other right you know it's
like they're always like you know it's
like Shawn was on in living color he
started doing comedy that way Marlon did
his thing they always had this like a
certain communal feel think it feels to
me with them like they that's what the
blueprint was like yeah a we're gonna
pull it off yeah we all won't pull each
other all right but I'm hearing from you
now it's like like cuz I always be like
how come Chris I never bring today and I
realize now that that's actually your
choice yeah yeah yeah what's up now
let's go back we're gonna go back so
when my mother found out that my brother
was doing stand-up she was upset
obviously
she was upset mom said to her and then
he said he was gonna leave school she
was more upset and then he's a trip one
night hanging out hoping somebody's late
so I can get a spot you know that you
know hoping that somebody runs like
you'd be at 10 minutes Eddie Murphy
walks in full this full Eddie Murphy now
this is yeah I know this is leather
glove it brings over the bluff with the
ten chicks and Moe and comes in my
brother's just you know a nobody at the
time he begs Lucien hole the manager to
introduce him to Eddie
Lucien introduces him Eddie so [ __ ]
cool so big don't mean nobody's a threat
to him he goes a is the kid going up and
uh
Lucian's like he's not on the list
tonight but if you would like to see him
I'll put him up and Eddie's like yeah
put him up and they all go imagine how
intimidating they all turn around and go
back in the room yeah yeah yeah so
watch his set and he will tell you this
to this day if you have him on here one
day he will tell you to this day that's
the best set he ever had in his life
could this day bring the pain in there
the best set ever the night Eddie Murphy
turned around and came back Nicholas and
that night he came home woke us all up
hey I met Eddie Murphy tonight he said
he's gonna put me in a movie oh wow hey
be careful with this cousin and bull
makes a noise Beverly Hills cops I of
the Hills Cop yeah
Miller Hills Cop - OH - yeah yeah yeah
and then we're thinking now we're
thinking we in the hood we thinking he's
famous and he just took him discovered
him and then the gift and the curse of
that was that everywhere he went was
Eddie Murphy discovered about Eddie
Murphy put him on Eddie Murphy and then
after that Eddie really didn't do much
he was yeah he saw Morris B was willie
morris and he didn't put him in harlem
nights which came after that and he
didn't put him in well he didn't miss
out on that yeah it's like a couple
movies that came after was that he
bought like I'm with Eddie now I'm down
with T nothing but then it would venture
at SNL yeah yeah SNL and we thought that
was amazing it was incredible and then
Iraq now is the black do don't hesitate
that's like that was like a credit now
around the same time my father passes
away hmm so the family's just
shell-shocked we all don't we don't know
what we're doing we don't know I'm in a
funk I'm I'm functioning but I'm not
functioning I'm by the way what are you
doing during this time so like when when
he when he you know he this thing
happened with Eddie Murphy I'm sure that
inspires you cop - I was in high school
okay right so you you trying to get out
of high school games like you chomping a
bit like I'm like all the girls in my
freshman class like is that you really I
heard that was your brother cuz some of
my boys went to the same high school
right no that's his brother yeah and all
the chicks I have we here - your brother
in the movie is now is that the moment
is that the moment that you started to
take advantage of that
uh never Olivia she look from 89 she was
like yo how can I get out of here to do
that yeah I feel you I gotta get out my
mother's not gonna let me circumnavigate
this high school your mom was on you at
that point so I gotta you ain't leaving
school get out of here listen up now I'm
in school I'm in high school and I'm
right in a little you know things I
think it's funny I'm like out the window
every day like man I just want to get
out of here and just be a star and then
I want to get teachers off mr. Rock yeah
they were filming they were filming uh
coming to America uh at the McDonald's
on Queens Boulevard the McDowell's my
high school everybody's like hey man can
we go meet Eddie Murphy can we go yeah
why we can't go meet him you put your
brother on right and I'm like like it
works like ya know baby I can't just
walk on the set like that so I'm in
school maybe two train stops away from
where they filming coming to America and
everybody's we go we leave it's cool we
gonna see Eddie Murphy we going and I'm
like I'm not doing that man he don't
know me like that I wanna come play
myself so I'm like I gotta get out of
school right right and uh I graduate now
you've always been like this by the way
I'm seeing this about you you are this
[ __ ] right here yeah yeah you
were very much not like we gonna have to
get to that you got to tell me the jay-z
story talking about that because that's
you you not to kind of do that get
starstruck yeah yeah yeah humility I
always thought it was a Brooklyn thing I
always thought it was a Brooklyn thing
that we just like yo okay he's hot but
I'm hot too yeah yeah yeah like I'm dope
too that's not I was like I'm Luke I
thought I was too cool so you get out of
schools I got out of high school and uh
my father passes away when I'm senior
gotcha and I had to go to summer school
that year to this was the crazy should I
had to go to summer school that year so
I didn't get my diploma until the first
day of school the following year had to
go to summer school all summer and my
father was already like kind of sick and
I came home
and my mother's on the couch sitting
with my dad and she's like just holding
him you know and I'm like mom I got to
show you something and I had a manila
envelope and she's like oh god what
please like she's like my diploma out
and she [ __ ] flies off the couch like
oh my god like I didn't think us was
gonna get out of high school that's
great and my dad is still she threw him
on yeah so he just reaches up and shakes
my hand he's like he's like stomach is
hurting him and he just reaches up like
it shakes my hand like good job and I
just remember that like I never got like
a big hug for my dad for graduating high
school is just like a handshake you know
it's all he could muster and my mother
was just through the roof and then now
of course it's like okay so now let's
see my college yeah you gonna be a
lawyer so she's like uh you know I was
like September so I couldn't register
for school that year so it was like what
are you gonna do you're gonna register
in January I think it was or you're
gonna work for a year what am i I'm like
I'll work for you I'll work for you and
as the comedy didn't go to college and
she's like okay well so that's the plan
uh-huh and now I'm out and I'm like I
gotta get on stage yeah yeah and my
cousin's sharad small works in New York
works to sell all the time he's working
in New York we would like throwback
ideas back and forth and I'm like we
gotta get on stage man and uh I get on
stage I think it was New York Comedy
Club and I bomb my ass off and they you
know they blew me and I'm like yeah it
was bull it was a booby on you no
question question because this is
important for this right here now at
this particular time were you in the
black club lane like did you know did
you want to do black audiences there's
no where were you at this time when I
used to sit in the fact in the strip and
watch all the comics they were mostly
white down right right right
and they were incredibly funny to me so
I never even looked at like a black line
I never looked at it's very urban you
didn't yeah there's you thought yourself
that what it's always taught and I'm I
think the the comedy gods for teaching
unis that funny is funny is funny right
I learned that day one like just like I
never looked at it like Oh black calm
go here Brian wake up I was like this
job ulcer is the whitest look at my
[ __ ] world and I'm crying
Dennis wolfburg is the weirdest-looking
white guy when he rest in peace
at the time curly-haired this skinny
eyes and will do the you know there's
what Burt yeah and I'm like Judas oh my
god like how how is he just funny so I
never thought black over here why don't
worry I never thought that you just got
a natural swag about you I just thought
it yeah I thought I thought you're black
if you're black you're black
yeah yeah you're gonna talk a little
different because anyway but you can
still be in wherever yeah yeah cuz yes
what your brother was doing Thomas C my
brother go on Adam saying oh yeah Asian
guy white woman so I was like okay as
long I guess as long as you funny that's
all that matters and that's what I
always subscribe to like just be funny
so you bombing in your son bomb it so I
bomb a bomb a couple times and I'm like
I [ __ ] this man like I don't I gotta
figure this [ __ ] out and I just stopped
going onstage and people are like my
boys like when you want backup and I'm
like I don't know man I'm I don't know
what the [ __ ] I gotta figure this [ __ ]
out I don't know and I didn't go on
stage for maybe months like four or five
I'm working at time so I'm going to work
and I'm like my boys like you doing some
this weekend I'm like nah I gotta work
man this is funny the same thing
happened to me man I know exactly where
you talk I know the exact feeling and my
boys are so excited about it the deal is
come on man like yeah and four months
I'm like that cuz that really cuz that
rejection of the crowd yeah like like
because you go up with this idea we had
so much excitement turned out a certain
way and it humbles you like humbling you
like damn I was so excited about this
thing and it turned out so it's actually
work yeah yeah so about one of my best
friend's to this day one of my best
friends Carlos grew up on a block with
me my mother was my mother used to
babysit him and his brother Keith so we
grew up as if we were brothers cuz they
spent the night at my household every
night then there ain't dinner at my
house my pops was a pops and Carlos
would always yell man when you go I'm
telling you bro you got to get back on
stage and I don't know why today I'm
telling you bro I seen it already
I seen it I'm you gonna be fine trust me
months later three months later I'm bruh
I'm telling you I'm Ted trust me man if
you never trust me before
I'm telling you that night you got booed
I saw it bro
I saw it I'm like no I'm food I was in
the room I saw yeah like I saw a
different you that night and months and
months and I go I all right I gotta get
back mistake and now I'm like I'm gonna
write a monster set I'm gonna be
creative and I'm gonna tell a story and
I'm gonna be me and I'm gonna you know
and I go to the strip and I sign up for
that a lot oh you know a lot of you get
any picked five comics they go on at
night the next five next Monday next
five Monday on today and I get like the
third Monday you know and I tell Carlos
like oh I got a spot and then they
called my house to confirm my spot I
come in the house and she's like why the
comic strip told you what the moment she
was like I'm like I'm just so dumb like
this isn't it funny how you think you
get over on your bed and you realize
like that wasn't gonna work yeah I'm
like I don't maybe they wanted to call
it's like you don't know what I call him
so I go on and I Lucien watches me and
he says uh he was impressed with my
writing and he's like you know come back
in two weeks and an audition again like
it's not a pass not a not it's a free
pass it's a come back come back and do
it again so I come back two weeks later
Lucia's there there's a couple of other
people there they watch me and like I'm
doing my thing I'm trying to get over to
stage fright now yeah I used to I used
to hold the mic I still hold the mic in
my hand hold the mic stand and look down
like this
really and Lucia's like well that's not
you have to I can't even have to connect
with the people yet so now look Mike's
tango so I walk in lift my head up saw
you know okay my boys like you know just
talk so I'm like you talk to us and to
this day I tell young comics would any
advice you'll talk to your people in the
audience like you talking to your boys
tell the jokes like you know they work
you did it before you told these jokes
before right well tell them like you
know they work yeah and then the the
comp tell my date tell them like
I would say uh I calm down and it
started and I got in a strip and uh then
it was like let's try the next club and
I got New York Comedy Club and then I
got stand-up New York and then I got in
Gotham now you are on your own and I'm
working and and my brother's doing his
thing and people are like yo you know
this is Christmas brother and people
that I go I like he's pretty good you
know so I never I'd never thought to be
like hey let's do it together
uh speed cuz he was already you know on
his way I was like I always thought it'd
be like you know it's like can you seal
it because I'm saying the way his
brothers doing it all the time you know
it's like you know they going on tour
together right I would love to be like
you know let's jam and let's do five
cities together yeah the rocks let's do
it your brother your brother
I would love yeah Jordan yeah yeah but I
just I just like this is the first time
by the way I've seen your brother Chris
actually start like talking about you
guys I know I kid you not sometimes I
feel I felt like I felt like early on I
felt like he would rather I wasn't in
the business mm-hmm I felt like that for
some time because now I will even
further back this is before comedy
growing up in bed-stuy Brooklyn I used
to follow my brother Charles around all
the time right so I was like you know
that's little Charles I was little
Charles nobody [ __ ] me in a
neighborhood my brother was kind of
picked on and bullied and he was big bro
and he was big brother I'm gonna tell
you sir always a big cooler he would get
his bike stolen right and I would get it
back man people would try to jump him
and I would come riding my bike gonna
feel like yo ain't nobody touches my
brother man right and it all [ __ ] tone
we could no longer got no problem with
you told I don't gonna well you can't
problem with him and not a problem and
it was a weird yes a weird dynamic
dynamic so now he does this thing that's
like okay I got this thing that I do
that's I'm really good at and here comes
Tom walking in the party like hey I do
this to ya
it's like [ __ ] man can I can I have my
old
yeah I get so so you got a natural take
for that reason I said oh no what I'm
not gonna bother him I'm gonna put all
my work in so I'll validate my spot
right so nobody will say Oh his brother
he coattail nepotism i will validate all
my success yeah because there for sure
was no nepotism directed movies don't
put you in rock Tony man no but I but I
think that that's like again it's a
testament to your your parents it really
is like he wanted that's him doing the
same thing you're doing he right well
I'm doing this on my own this is right
right no one's doing it for me I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna be great yeah and then
you're doing the same thing I remember
like this is our childhood I'm like you
know summer school and my mother's like
I mean it's a school summer school's out
for the summer and my dad's like we have
to all have to have jobs for the summer
and my brother gets a job and
everybody's working and I'm looking for
a job and one of my friends worked at a
sneaker store and I'm like ill man and a
hiring and he's like I'll talk to the
manager I'll see if I can get you in and
my dad's like did you look for a job
today and I'm like no I'm uh you know uh
my man boo said he gonna hook me up in a
sneaker store and my father's like no no
you don't do hookups you don't do you
don't do this guy gets you a job you get
you a job you don't do you don't wait
for the worker to get you to but you you
go get the job you know I mean like we
don't do hookup so you don't do we don't
do that so I've always been like I'm
gonna get my own I we were taught to get
all yeah that's funny that you have like
a very like it's a you know humility
about you about this kind of thing and I
think that's great I realized I was
comin I tell you all of that my mother
was a schoolteacher my father was a
truck driver I treat people like my
mother's a schoolteacher and my father's
a truck driver yeah and yes you do you
know like I said I was telling you
they're like you would tell me one time
y'all saw jay-z you with your brother
and your mother was like let's go you
know yeah you knew it was gonna be a
situation is my little
I'll do it invite for my right he's like
can we please think I'm like come on man
like yeah I'm like hey man come a little
bit Engels may take the picture man the
whole image I had of you yeah yeah so
I'm like but I did it for my little
brother yeah yeah yeah what I was cool
too welcome to Jay Z so do you think
that now that like you're older now yeah
Kris is older you guys have gone through
the fire of the certain parts of the
business and I say I really like I was
on his Instagram the other day and he
was like doing like a question and
answer with his fans and they said they
said he was like my brothers are funnier
than me Tony he's funnier than me
Jordans funnier than me you know this is
what he's saying on anything so he's out
there talking about you I mean I feel
like it
are we moving towards what you guys can
finally be like you wanna help each
other I'm ready I'm ready
I got a broker to do I think the comedy
fan base the comedy you know the comedy
what's what the solar system yeah would
love to see that I would be like yo that
I gotta tell you dope [ __ ] right now I
think I've told you this but like one
really great moment for me I've had two
of them now that involve your brother
because one day I was at the Comedy
Store and I'm just doing a regular set
right you know what I mean and they told
me you know they're they always that you
know Chris Rock might be coming all
right you know and so I thought I was
bringing him up but it didn't it didn't
work because I think he was waiting for
somebody but anyway I'm standing outside
talking with a couple comics your
brother comes out to Oh our he sees me
he be lines over to me not he's a weird
[ __ ] okay
he's actually all socially awkward he's
so socially awkward like he will walk
right by you you know I mean like in
fact like he's not a dick he just all
right he be lines to me and he's like yo
you will work funny and like doing the
fingers and everything I mean you was
really funny an enemy who are you what
should we have
and then
these two comics are Stinney he don't
even exist
and I'm like you know I'm having this
conversation with him he's like yeah
boom boom walks away and then the two
guys look at me they're like what you
know and I was like god it's weird but
it to me else I just felt so validated
my whole way everything I do i yeah it
leaves you no work but you know so I was
like it really was like them but you
know it's funny fifteen minutes later I
saw him in a parking lot the
[ __ ] didn't even know me
you know and I was like okay I'm back to
ya know but another thing that he just
had his birthday right yes yes so I go
on Instagram cuz I'm gonna I just think
give me just shot in the dark
cinema DM happy birthday he's already
following me and I wasn't following
he'll be back thanks man and I was like
damn well you got millions of followers
I think he's really coming down you know
kids that grow older now yeah yeah yeah
yeah the divorce is done he's back out
in the world it's like you know what
it's life ain't that serious yeah a
little fun like something have you done
shows you've done shows you your other
brother why have you info job my man
hunter grid
oh my guy like that's you know yours man
yeah okay I thought I didn't yeah yeah
yeah it's like I love him too he's like
man yes so funny y'all was so different
too yeah
you know you're so different and Jordan
grew up a little different you Jordan
asked my father passed my mother moved
back to South Carolina where she was
from
Oh Jordan was a baby and uh he missed
everything he was him is the poorness
yes like really he moved to South
Carolina big-ass house yeah yes backyard
basketball court yeah yeah yeah
bikes in the front yard my kid we didn't
we didn't grow up like this yeah hilarya
and he lived
with my mom well my baby sister had just
left for college might be let me a few
years later so he had that he was in a
house with my mom just them two so I'm
like you don't even have the same mother
I have breath like you got a different
mother so let me ask you about this now
um so you're you're out here in the
comedy world right now and so what I
mean what do you think about like what's
happened socially how it's affected
comedy how's it affected your comedy the
me to movement being in the Trump era
everything that's happening right now
has it affected your comedy and in what
way uh wall material everything that
goes on in the world's materials for me
as far as I'm concerned you got to find
that that that line in it that you
couldn't address in it that that stage
you take and be able to you know
articulate it with some humor me to
movement is uh it was big so you as a
comic you have to address it
of course I the me to movement is uh
it's weird like you know I'm not gonna
do bits but it was like it's guys that
were weird to begin with that got in
positions of power but they still were
weird it's like I've seen a mean one
town it's like uh I said you know you
can have money and still be corny yeah
you said you do realize you could have
money and still be corn that's why
there's web sounds like you don't get
you don't get alien air Matchmaker you
don't get uncor Newt you don't get
unwired you don't get unn whatever
because you in a position but did you
find it where it was like so like you
know let's say pre me to movement you
might have had like say a a chauvinistic
type joke you know right did it affect
how you did not no no I I still do
stand-up I still write the same way but
now this is the thing when you write I
think I think for most comics ludus now
you write the joke and then you have to
really you're more thoughtful what a is
this could this be misconstrued as
saying this could this be could they
take this away from this cuz then I have
to change it you know so you're more you
kind of go over it more finally
everything you say I think that the
social media and even team even when
stand-up started to go on TV more
remember back in the day was like
evening at The Improv a list that's yeah
I personally feel like that was the
worst thing to ever happen to comedy
to know about oversaturation the
oversaturation of it and now it now cut
to you have Netflix do you want to talk
about oversaturating comedy yeah like
it's just like you're gonna be the next
thing is gonna be like a two minute show
you know you know me like or does they
do like a show like 85 comics do in two
minutes it's gonna be like what do we do
right now you know it's like so I feel
like the the live experience is will
always be the best it would always be
the best boys do the best but the live
experience is being taken away because
people want to tape it you know and
people want to like you know oh this
happened at the club and not now it's a
you know we're gonna put it out here you
know I was in my fan of Louie but I just
thought didn't think that was a fair for
them to like tape him as he's working
out of some what it is right right
inappropriate or not like it's like you
said you saw my brother when he's
working out stuff and in three weeks
later it's monster yeah you tape it when
it's nothing and put it up now people
like yeah or he might have said
something that we don't have the luxury
now because social media we don't have
the luxury of the workout yeah the
workout is public now yeah Nessa well
you got to let us work out it's part of
it is this necessity of the job we have
to work out now you tape it I was in
Sacramento this past weekend I come on
on stage two minutes in hey what's up
sack girls like this with phone
following me oh so I'm like sweet are
you taping the show what are you doing
and she goes nah I'll tape half and so I
stopped I said I'll just stopped until
it you put the phone away
and I just sit there and the whole rooms
like come on put the phone away the
Thrones you and understand them and it
hurt I'm sure her ego was like nobody
got she'sshe's acting up and there's
some guy and it backs like man you ain't
that famous do your damn job
oh so now I'm like you know what I'm
gonna go the other way I was gonna curse
them out and I go the other way I go
bruh you know understand what's going on
here
she's taping my show I didn't say
anything disrespectful to her I didn't
call a [ __ ] I didn't say hold the phone
yeah she just I'm gonna tape half your
show why do you think that's cool bruh
how to do that to tape the show the
people that paid money to sit here
they're these are the guys I'm doing the
show for now for the people she's gonna
send the show to later on maybe I'm
working on jokes maybe I'm gonna try
something new tonight yeah why does she
get to send it up alright man Joe will
do she put the phone well that's what
I'm saying bro and the security is like
you want to out of my mouth
Trudy should have win over me like
against our table I saw dave chappelle
one night at the factory he said people
folks are polled phones out and he goes
hey how about we do this how about we
put our phones away and let's have a
human experience do I you'll leave here
tonight and you'll tell your friends I
saw Dave Chappelle last night and they
say oh [ __ ] didn't you get to say you
missed it man why can't we miss Atlanta
punchline and there was a there was a
drunk couple and I'm starting to handle
them do pulls out his phone away what
are you doing man he was like we're
doing so good right now say hey why
don't we just enjoy this moment let you
do it human experience just enjoy this
moment whatever happened to you missed
it oh my god you had to be there you
liked me you should have seen now people
like look I just and it's a piece of it
so you don't get the whole story is like
this you know what's make you know what
is you know what this is doing it Sweden
after the the week comics write it sweet
is reading them out it's mean that the
ones that they don't have the stomach
for this they don't have the work ethic
for it yeah they don't have the ability
or skill to do it because it's just
getting rid of them get out of here yeah
you can't do this but then you know they
do they're the guys that are in your
comments like you suck you a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude come on do you read comments
sometimes sometimes I'll post something
I think it's funny and I'm like I was
kind of good oh you suck you the worse
is when you go through like six really
good comments and after when you want to
respond to I just comment is this this
is what it is especially with the
negativity and I don't want it I don't
want to get to sound like whatever they
say there's it's a reflection of how
they feel about themselves possibly so
when it's like it in my comments it kind
of feels that way it's you ain't [ __ ]
bro you just Chris Rock brother this guy
feels intimidated by like he must be the
guy in his group that's not doing what
he wants to do in his life so but you
you probably let that go I get I'm like
oh come on man you had that goal on top
we got it's like you
I got to take a picture with a chick you
know you know out for the night with
baby girl you ain't got no trust me Tony
guy ya know same Andes it's just like
they just they see the void in their
lives and they like I just want to put
it on somebody else yeah it's crazy they
say I can't stand it but it's like you
know sorry but you know it's weird like
the comments you know what the original
comments for us are are where the show
we're doing a show and you look out and
150 people are laughing but there's that
one person that's going like this yeah
that's the movie fun that's the one I'm
like what's your [ __ ] problem killing
right now you know I don't like this you
know whatever it is and then just like
we before go like we like we forget
psyche at a comic ah 150 people in a
room but in 49 like the one guy you like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this dude
just take that yeah I want off
wonderfully night leave just take their
there you are gonna laugh Muhammad Ali
said if 500,000 people come to see me
fight two hundred and fifty thousand
came to see me lose yeah true enough
so it's gonna be that in the room but as
a comic you like know that's the guy I
want we know as funny as I at a comedy
club the people that laugh outweigh to
people that don't and we don't hear that
right so this is like three other people
to Laugh Factory you know it's like this
go be 25 there might be like we like
this dude but I don't even hear it you
know right but what happens on a mass
scale when you do a special or you do
let you know then you're talking about
that section of that 24 that percentage
right is actually a lot of people write
write write write write who don't like
you yeah I mean but yet that's all part
of the all part of the payment that's
the business we in isn't is like
everybody's not gonna like you this is
what we do we do what we do a job that's
like everybody I like it and they're
like it and that's the hard thing you
rattling me I appreciate it but see
that's what happened to me is like my
story is like I was doing a show of
mixed nuts which is now the comedy Union
oh that's right yeah
yes when I would start first starting
out you started in LA I started I'm from
LA I started it all hey it was a
nightmare
well I think it was East Coast now
because I got family I got that look
okay because you know a Puerto Rican
dude it is like it was mixed you know so
I I meant I'm at mixed nuts and then
like you know J Anthony Brown is the
host and this was around Clinton Monica
Lewinsky stuff the host the host like
brings him up and she don't tell him
who's going up next
he's killing I'm talking about smashing
the crowd he looks over to commies who
next all the comics like take one step
back I felt like it was just saying you
know I'm like okay I guess I'm gonna
Eric Griffin you know I got you know
then that's that black intro I don't
know who does my bug is I don't know
he'd I know you don't got no credit you
know yeah I'm getting roasted before
even go on so I go on and then like I'm
doing terrible yeah you know a minute in
he's giving me the light oh wow and I
say two words I got the light already
you know and then so I finish up he
proceeds to go on and do 20 minutes on
you saying about how horrible I was I
know he's killing today to this day I
remember him say it [ __ ] you got the
light people send a girlfriend Oh fine I
get you off stage you know and dude I'm
sitting out on a stool at the bar and
I'm telling myself as a man I don't
leave I don't walk out of here a coward
none of the car none of the comics we
want to talk to me like there's like a
bubble of negativity around me they
don't want that [ __ ] on them you know
what I mean and I tell you that like
like you said you stopped for a month
right I stopped for years okay I didn't
I had been I've been tired of trying to
go to open mics and rather figure this
out you know right and so that was the
one that I was like I'm out right I
can't you know and so I I stopped doing
it for such a long time yeah then when I
got back into it finally one of my
finally one of my boys was that was
there for me someone a child I don't
have a lot of friends so I didn't have
that guy that's like yo man you could do
it till way later and then I remember
doing a show I was doing this show
called it was at Marley
Dan Majerle and Phoenix yeah yeah yeah
member marlie so this stuff right there
nail with a pessimist thing yeah yeah
it's like an outdoor no no I said it was
an indoor bar but it was like oh you got
that they got the sprinklers and [ __ ]
outside cuz it's so hot and right right
so they having a show and I don't know
it's a all-black show right
I don't know cuz they flying you out
there's a dude with a sign at the
airport and I was excited I was like oh
[ __ ] I'm making it rare Griffin at the
airport get to the show it's like mad
ghetto okay and I'm in the back like oh
no the host is bombing he brings me up
I'm trying my best when I got off the
hostess bomb the host is why when I got
offstage deejay played okay host goes
back on and the joke becomes Eric
Griffin ain't coming back to this club
you know that became the joke but I
gotta tell you something I was in the
back and I was laughing I was in the
back like I I just didn't have it
tonight right and it didn't matter to me
right that's when I knew I can make it
let me tell you can ask the moment I
knew I can make and I please tell you
this to at least go ahead you and you
said you stayed in the room it was like
okay I got comic strip New York City
it's summertime in New York it's the
weekend of the Puerto Rican Day Parade
if you've never been in New York the
weekend at a Puerto Rican a parade it's
the biggest Puerto Rican festival from
Friday to Sunday you will ever see they
parade down Central Park West I guess
they party all as cars running lights
and girls like wearing the least they
can wear legally in the streets the
comic strip is packed that night 8
o'clock show packed 10 o'clock show 12
o'clock show everybody's like yeah we
gonna see comedy a roomful of rowdy
drunk
poor I'm on a 10 o'clock show I get
onstage table to my right a bunch of
Puerto Rican guys now stages here right
so tables like almost like behind you
yeah table to the left table full of
Puerto Rican girls gorgeous pouring
girls
dude honest on my right is Holloman
across the state like let's say he's
sitting here like at Sierra's table is
she's sitting at the in business and
he's here by me but it's because and I'm
standing the dude they talking dude puts
his foot up comes on the stage walks
behind me kneels down it's the girls
number comes back I'm like yo at this
time now you see me do crowd let's take
over a room just don't crowd riffing i
got nothing i got nothing this early on
this girl is right
mm you wish that what happened now
whatever i go hey man oh don't do that
again
and he's like shut the [ __ ] up man you
just met cuz you bombing and the whole
table all his boys like oh oh you bomb
the [ __ ] takes the lemon wedge
out his drink and throws the [ __ ] at me
oh my god the whole room is like oh
number immediate lesson learned
bombing most of the time is losing
control of the room yes
it's not the jokes not work yes it's
losing control of the room yeah I lost
control of the room immediately
they started booing I'm standing there
I'm like I see the light come on I'm
like [ __ ] I gotta fight this guy man you
I bomb and you you Bob like I don't know
what the [ __ ] to say a bottom you you
you crazy for Regan crazy dude Allah
corny man you cook lights on flickering
up oh gosh I just step back from the mic
I'm sitting in the lobby of the lab
right I think of the comic strips sorry
and I'm like my boys are dead I'm like
let's get the [ __ ] outta here my cousin
Sharad goes no no we're not getting the
[ __ ] out oh good I wish I had a good
you're gonna sit you're gonna sit right
here you're gonna sit right here right
and the show lets out and comic strip
holds what 220 225 [ __ ] walk
past me yo Justin do right here he's
[ __ ] suck yo papi yo my man is the
[ __ ]
gyrate girls welcome past like Oh
puppies so sorry baby but 225
[ __ ] and we they all walk and
I'm just like head down here yeah yeah
and sherrod goes I want you to remember
that you know why cuz that's never gonna
happen again
boom and that [ __ ] was like like Bane
turn the [ __ ] knob and I was just
like okay that's never gonna happen to
me again and it was just like right and
every day we want stage as much as
possible riffing throwing stuff out
somebody say so you say boa will make
that funny bull now I'm when I can all
say now I can I tell you all the time I
swear I feel like I can see better here
better when I'm on stage
cuz anything happens I'm ready for
anything yeah I feel I know exactly ever
happened to me again you know I I like
to do it when I'm doing it along set I
like to do comedy to the point where the
crowd is weird with but the crowd is
completely silent like they are because
they are like this right right what are
you going about to say next yeah and
sometimes I take a moment where I'm like
I love that because that is I like to
see it I like to see their faces like
the helico to make control is like
they're waiting for you to say the next
thing because you can't that's whole
crap that's when they're locked in they
logged in I locked it you know nobody
you know a whole set of them laughing is
like that's not a very remember it it's
like you want you want the lab you want
to want to yeah I heard that yeah never
laugh you want all that you're saying
you want the whole spectrum
I just recently did have you ever done I
just did the Atlanta comedy theater like
a couple months back see I didn't know
you already laughing this is exactly
what I'm talking about
let me see how many people that you
didn't know we're in your green room
first up not luckily they have two green
rooms now oh use like the other one yes
no yet I took the one with the TV oh my
god no I'm like I'm not gonna sit in the
middle TV I mean that means like every
comic in Atlanta did a guess that to the
point where they'll tell you they did
Lana right I'm domestic I went in the
room close the door just tell me what
I'm coming on yeah I'm coming
you ride up sure and then I feel like
I'm waiting and then like I draw a weird
crowd so I got some like white people
Asian people coming to that all-black
theater and they sitting in the crowd
like they can't believe what they're
witnessing so after a while I had this
heart you had to dress their head listen
I would say I didn't know it was this
black either you don't just play a song
he come up like yo man which biggie
album you want me to play before you go
up got it enjoyable but one of my
favorite compliments I got cuz I still
do my set yeah yeah yeah just like just
like maybe older black man he comes up
to me he goes poignant said brother
poignant said and I was like I just I
felt what he was talking about yes you
know to me so that's what I'm saying
like it's different types of reactions
you get from people I have to show you
want people to be like that was funny
you want people to be like yeah man you
really made me think about stuff and or
you want people to be like oh yeah we on
the same page thinking like I think and
it's just it's weird that's why I love
doing this I did a said it's a factory
the other night and I it was a new joke
I wanted finessed Mitchell to hear it so
he was in the back room I'm like I'm
gonna try it why so he don't steal it
[Laughter]
[Music]
front row for white girls like West
bel-air white girls this is like sitting
in front row Hey ladies and the joke was
a how black people limit themselves by
saying certain things are white and it's
like the bigger picture is you know our
parents and our grandparents raised us
they're from a different era so people
say like you know you going to the beach
oh you know what's white [ __ ] but if you
really think about it it's because my
grandmother wasn't allowed on the beach
right when she was like my age black
people weren't allowed on the beach so
to her it became the beach was white it
was deemed white her she taught my
mother we can't go there so they she
thought it was white so I said uh but
now we if you don't take advantage of
these opportunities you know the fault
lies with you now because we have these
opportunities so and I was like you
ain't gonna do
if you black do it black who white stuff
but do it black and I got a DM the next
night from the for white girls they were
like that joke was so thought-provoking
I know you said you were doing it for
your friend in the back so he could hear
it but I never thought of things like
that I never looked at it like that and
she's like I really appreciate you
taking a chance and saying that and
because I said man fools if this was
black night they would go crazy over
this joke and she said I appreciate you
for you know trying it out tonight in
front of us and I'm like that's good man
I like I like to hear the growth yes man
where we at man how we doing error oh
[ __ ] okay let me right there look at
that
what we supposed to do I just do an hour
I mean it's good I mean I feel like you
and I could keep target for everything I
just thought yeah please please I wasn't
gonna address it but and I'm not this is
not be for anger and anything you were
on fire last night at the Comedy Store
right I think I was too after you right
so while I'm wrapping my setup I hear
but before I went on I hear them like
yeah he's gonna go on after Tony he said
he wants to go on after Tony so I'm
thinking about self somebody's in the
room uh-huh I go on I do my set Dice
Clay was after me Oh God
so he goes on his Instagram I can pull
up the video if you want to see it oh
you pull it up that lid on and he's like
mid to Comedy Store I'm going on after
Tony rock and he's taping the other
comics like did you guys know Tony rock
and Eleanor's like dude everybody knows
Sonja rock what you talking about
and he's like he's Chris's brother it's
like three videos he posts he post them
on Instagram and he's like a does Chris
know that he's using the name so I said
wait does he think it's a you know my
brother all these years we didn't know
this is a family name so I'm not using
my brother's name oh he thinks is like a
stage yeah I'm like this my family name
so that was weird but then he said uh so
Chris knows that he performs here and
Eleanor's like dude what are you talking
about like what's wrong with you yeah
all the comments like Tony's dope like
he's me all the time you never saw Tony
like Tony yeah and then he says well I'm
just saying it
my brother was on stage doing stand-up
here I would drag him off the stage
that'd be the end of that and I'm like
he thinks I should be dragged off the
stage because what like I don't and when
you text me like new to do the podcast
like yeah I'll talk about it tomorrow
and then it was going so good and I was
like you know what maybe I'm not I don't
get it like it was like dude it was that
weird that Cleveland you talk about a
different error like he's been on one
recently I he was talking about like you
know so I don't know I mean I mean I
don't know him that well right you know
I he was like he's a fan of I'm dying
appear so like he's been like you know
he said yeah I love you on the show and
this and that but it's like I don't know
I mean you know you here's somebody that
was like so super famous and then now
it's like you know now he's famous for
something else I did the documentary
yesterday too for the comedies not all
right I taped it in the daytime and then
they came back to take my set that the
last night so uh in the documentary I
said when I first heard about The Comedy
Store it was Richard Pryor goes in there
and all the comics stand and it's
standing room only and they just watched
Richard Pryor then I heard Eddie Murphy
goes up at the Comedy Store he walks in
with Robert Townsend in Keenan IPO and
they shut down the club and everybody
just stops what they're doing to see
Eddie Murphy and then I I'm saying this
verbatim and I heard Dice Clay would
come in and he would just be he was the
biggest thing in comedy he would come to
the comedy store and the room would just
come to a halt and all of this I heard
was about the comedy store so when I was
in New York not even doing stand-up at
the time I just thought when I get to
California one day I have to go to the
Comedy Store yeah and I'm giving this
dude the biggest props okay and I get
the other night he's like who the [ __ ]
is this guy's that's Chris know his
brothers feeling the last night I was
like just saying he's the biggest moment
and he's like he should be dragged off
the stage like wow I was crazy it shows
you it could flip like that yeah yeah
well what's that thing they say about
meeting your idols yeah man yeah it was
but what is uh the idols becoming rivals
that one or that's one two yeah well
that's what happens in this game you
know you know that's that definitely
happens you know you when you start like
you know all this to
it didn't all of a sudden you like oh
whoa whoa it was actually on you're in
the same and then it kind of changes
yeah when you're down here they like a
kid day and then you up here or
neck-and-neck - well you know this is
like like what comedy right now is like
rap music
cuz rap is large always been rap music
but it's nothing a black the black
comedy I've always been right but but
check it out now you this is the first
time we're seeing old rappers right you
know like you're old now yeah like kids
don't even know if people think loq J's
are actor you know what I mean they know
Run DMC they're you know running from
runs house yeah yeah they don't know
that these people are and I think that
that's starting to happen with those big
comics from the 80s - or people are like
you know they're forgetting about like
right because the famous guys they know
now from phrases yeah you know we want
you know not but to get there yeah man
so yeah they kind of why wouldn't take
it - you know what I say I wouldn't take
it to person I didn't I didn't I was
like you know I just like yeah it was
weird but it's weird you know it's like
one Elinor had your back you know yeah
see you know what the rest I was leaving
she said she came home like you know he
didn't even know like he yeah cuz I was
telling him like dude are you crazy like
in the video she's like dude what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you like yeah
everybody knows Tony Rock
it's just what it's just one of those
he's like he's here all the time he's
here [ __ ] every night not know that
he's not here every day my boy was like
it just shows how out of touch he is
yeah yeah yeah you know he was good in
the Lady Gaga movie but uh she's being
good as a drunk father and like he's get
into a stars born yes stars in it he
plays her father but anyways you know we
don't squash that beef you know but I
want to thank Tony for coming on I have
you on it again I guess more we Qatari
didn't get to the Clippers we closer to
playoff you get some me moving to LA and
all that is oh you have so much more to
talk about but I you know we can that
good part we're gonna call this apart
one with Tony rock that's it we're gonna
have a part two I'm glad you came on I
really appreciate you doing this and I
wish you much success
what's up for the future for you right
now what's going on right now I'm trying
to
the number one thing is I'm trying to
get this hour done so I can showcase it
and get this out with specialized you
gotta get it yeah yeah that's because
it's all about content right rights not
even about it and I think it's a game
change I think like it wouldn't be a
who's this guy if I had you know I had a
I was special everybody if you're real
comic you're gonna be like I I gotta
check it out yeah yeah real comics well
I will look forward to that I'm sure
it'll be someplace yes yeah no I'm sure
to be someplace and then anything else
you got like TV work what's up pictures
of stuff yeah I did a sitcom I was on a
CBS got canceled I was the highest
tested guy they told me on the of the
cast
so now CBS is trying to keep me in the
fold so now hey his idea let's try to
that's good well we look for Tony on TV
yes yes gonna have maybe him and I be
together to do it
like tango and cash like we could be
detectives that we should do black
riptide you know how they make it like
old shows Riptide you don't remember
riptides Wow look the Riptide they had
two pink helicopter it was a detective
show in the eighties never her
Edmonton's steel Riptide no real Aaron
knows rip remember you know you ain't
[ __ ] Aaron was like a fake ass Magnum
was yeah it was like oh my god I'm a
hunter yeah okay hunter heart to heart
it was Merida it was when they got
together it was married yeah I mean okay
well we'll figure something out we don't
figure something out it'll be a cop show
or something anyways thanks for watching
thanks for listening keep subscribing
please share and I appreciate everything
that you guys send me and send me some
keep sending theme songs and keep
sending ideas thank you very much for
watching it from a Griffin and once
again please thanks to Tony Rock thank
you my shelf recession I appreciate you
my brother and that's it thank you
[Applause]